there's been quite a lot of movement
this week in the war it's been static
for a little while but this week we can
see things are actually moving with the
uh the fact that the russians have now
finished with mario paul they've got
their land bridge the land bridge that
runs from the donbass through to crimea
and a little bit further westwards and
that land bridge will take some
recapturing if the uh ukrainians really
want to push back in this war at some
time later on
for now all the attention is on the
donbass the donbass region where the
russians are pursuing this bite and hold
strategy bite a piece of territory and
then hold it and where they're trying to
bite and hold at the moment centers on
two main areas over the last uh 48 hours
or so one is from prophasna they took
the passenger a little while ago high
ground very useful they didn't seem to
do much with it but now they're moving
out they're moving westwards and
northwards from papasna and trying to
push forwards towards verio severo
donetsk and that actually is the essence
of this battle at the moment severio
donetsk that city is really important to
them they've got it surrounded on three
sides they've tried a couple of times to
get round to the other side to the west
of it that didn't go very well but the
russians will undoubtedly try again and
severe don yet is the center of the
current battle that we're seeing in the
donbass a little bit further north uh
isiam a very important center the
russians took it some time ago they
haven't made that much progress going
southward from museum although they've
tried the ukrainians have held them
there but they've tried to push north
now from lyman and through lymon they're
trying to link up with izium and they
may succeed in doing that but the
ukraines are putting up quite stiff
resistance so those are the areas within
the donbass where at the moment the
fighting is most intense
a couple of other matters of interest
recently uh liz trust the british
foreign secretary said that uh we would
be prepared britain would be prepared to
send weapons to moldova to help moldova
defend itself against any future uh
russian attack well that might be an
important political statement but in the
immediate sense um it's not terribly
relevant because moldova is in a very
delicate state the army of moldova is
only five or six thousand troops the
separatists in moldova the russian
separatists have militias that are
bigger than the moldovan army and the
russians themselves have 1 500 troops in
moldova who are technically peacekeepers
the united un says they're not
peacekeepers and has ordered them to
leave several times and the russians
just ignore it so sending weapons into a
volatile situation will probably create
a new civil war in moldova and the
country might fall apart so in the
immediate sense sending weapons to
moldova is irrelevant it might become
relevant a bit later on and the other
thing that's happened in the last 24
hours or so is that the germans have
confirmed that they're going to send the
gephard uh anti-aircraft tank to uh uh
ukraine they've promised this a little
while ago these are the uh the gephard
anti-aircraft based basically a tank
chassis with anti-aircraft system on top
they're very good
the germans have said they're sending 15
of them not 150 or 50 15 of them
and they announced it originally in
april they confirmed it now and they
will arrive in july
meantime
the ukrainians are going to have to hold
on in the donbass in the under the
pressure that they are currently
suffering